hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer folge an ver mario
ich wollte das ganze letzten schon mal
irgendwann aufnehmen allerdings war die
website einfach weil ich war eigentlich
schon bei drei oder vier und jetzt muss
ich allerdings wieder von 1 anfangen
weil es halt irgendwie nicht geklappt
hat dann seid ihr dran
es ist halt echt scheiße ich kann mich
auch nicht mehr daran erinnern wo die
ganzen fallen waren wir über ihr drauf
jetzt hier jetzt man denkt so jan luca
du hast das doch schonmal so alles
gespielt das kann man doch dann
eigentlich wissen tut man nicht weil er
der teil wo ich das gespielt habe den
verlinke ich euch mal hier der ist aber
schon ich glaube der ist echt schon
lange her also irgendwie blogger 23
monate oder soll ich diese blöcke da
jetzt von oben oder ich noch mal okay da
ist der checkpoint ich wusst ich wusste
ich hab's gewusst es war klar dass einer
von den beiden soll hier raus hier rüber
achja nadeln springe einfach hier
das war auch wieder ein klasse rand
einfach auf den ersten drauf und jetzt
ganz easy
was soll dieser blog ich traue mich
nicht weiter zu laufen bei mir überall
verein sein könnten
einfach geschafft wir sind jetzt in
level 2 wo wir hier bist du die sache
seit ich würde wirklich ganz gern diese
schule
was ist das denn wir über ach ja
natürlich fällt er da ein hier über die
stacheln drüber jetzt hier gegen
springen hier hoch drüber oder drunter
man wisst ihr was wir jetzt mal als test
machen freunde das video geht jetzt
uncut weiter wisst ihr was wir jetzt mal
machen freundlich nehmen das video jetzt
einfach mal an karten natürlich falle
ich dabei das video wird jetzt anstatt
weiter gehen das heißt ich werde ab
jetzt wirklich nicht mehr schneiden ich
werde nicht die musik unter setzen
lassen ich werde nichts machen nicht an
die face kamran so nicht sondern jetzt
wie ich einfach an katze ich wollte das
einfach mal testen wie das so ist wie
das ankommt wenn ich mal nicht schneiden
sollte weil ich habe teilweise echt
abends wenn ich nach dem praktikum nach
hause komme ist es halt dann meistens
schon wenn ich alles erledigt habe so 11
uhr abends und ich muss dann jetzt haben
wir oft und dann sind sie meistens noch
vier stunden im video und wenn ich mal
so ein antrag video hochladen würde dann
so montags immer uncut tag und keine
ahnung was dann könnte man das ja
vielleicht mal einführen aber ich mache
jetzt erstmal
wir springen hierüber sind hier auf den
komischen blöcken drauf jetzt müssen wir
darauf achten dass ihr mein gott da
drunter bleiben und hier mein gott war
das enger da kommen welche runter okay
hier vorne sind aufstacheln
das will ich aber auch nicht ausreizen
und jetzt warum kriegt dem ich denn da
dass man noch keinen sinn ich bin extra
dem makler bot sich dann block in der
luft auf ich werde nicht mehr
daher sei nicht zu übermütig hier hoffen
hier darüber jetzt haben gott natürlich
nimmt er mich mit hochbahn
es war so klar es war klar ich hasse
dieses spiel
hier könnt ihr wieder drunter her genau
jetzt hier hoch und gemeiner deswegen
sage ich euch jetzt mal das ist das
spiel auch ein krieg kann
scheiße kann doch auch nicht sein ich
weiß nicht ich glaube so ein spiel macht
keinen sinn dass man es an kann hoch
legen weil das schneiden witziger wenn
man stellen nicht weiter kommt einfach
aber bei so was wie auch egal ich hab'
war doch jetzt echt nicht bei dir auf
der höhe dass du mich damit nehmen
können oder sollen absacker dieses spiel
das ist einfach wenn man ein scheißtag
hat macht dieses spiel schafft es den
tag einfach noch beschissener zu machen
das ist ja echt ich hab's voll verlieren
an einem stück zu kommentieren deswegen
bin ich auch kein letzter sondern
einfach nur ein blöder kann ich zurück
springen ach natürlich sind da die
komischen
alles klar ich bin ich jetzt wissen
natürlich sind die da auch gut an
ferrari ohne die ganzen und fern fallen
ihm habe ich dort geschrieben ich bin
auch blöd den anfang machen wir uns ohne
die ganzen uns herfallen wer einfach
mario einfach nett ich dann gar nicht
drauf viele sagen immer zu mir ja nu
karten machen wir hier
da die alte zeit war noch vielen reisen
wo du noch mehr geredet hat wo die
videos länger als fünf sechs minuten
waren mir macht es spaß zu schneiden
dabei ist nimmt halt extrem viel zeit in
anspruch deswegen den checkpoint meine
damen und herren viele denken dass ich
kürze videos mache weil es für mich
schneller geht und ich damit dann halt
schneller geld verdienen kann was
überhaupt nicht stimmt weil ich an einem
kürzeren video erstes weniger geld
verdiene weil ich nicht diese heftige
netz schalten kann die ich meinem langen
video schalten kann und es dauert halt
auch viel länger das kommt dann auch
noch dazu also einen tag alter
ich kann das nie mehr machen jetzt auch
gerade aufgefallen dass ich gerade
wahrscheinlich schon 23 mal wieder
geschnitten habe ja nichts dafür aber
ich musste gerade etwas wegschubsen ich
weiß ich habe gerade auch schon wieder
ein bisschen ich habe glaub ich geh
kaputt gemacht ich weiß ich habe jetzt
gerade geschnitten und ich weiß auch
dass ich vorhin wahrscheinlich ein paar
mal als ich so uncut gelabert habe dass
ich da wohl auch wieder geschnitten habe
weil ich einfach ich bin einfach in
diesem film drin so dass ich das halt
dauerhaft schneider deswegen verzeiht
mir dass ich da ab und ab und zu
trotzdem geschnitten habe aber trotzdem
meine lieben freunde es war für mich
selber man so ein test ob ich noch kann
so ein bisschen anders machen wir haben
es euch gefallen hat wäre es auf jeden
fall weiß oder wenn ihr eine idee habt
ob ich das demnächst nochmal machen soll
vielleicht ein bisschen komplett uncut
mal wieder der minecraft uncut oder
woran er war dann schreibt man in die
kommentare und ich bin ich bin jetzt bin